one step closer to regulation of the
banking sector as meps approved a draft
report on the financial transaction tax
on tuesday
11 member states have signed up to the
financial tax which could come into
force by early 2014
and popular with the industry it looks
to end short-term speculation and
promote growth via long-term investment
i think this is extremely important for
european citizens one year ahead of the
european
elections the european parliament has
been able to send a clear message
that their concerns and their priorities
are taken very seriously
into consideration it's not only the
normal taxpayers that are assuming the
burden of the crisis
softening the stance on austerity
tackling unemployment and
strengthening growth were high on the
agenda on monday as commissioners olly
ran and laszlo andor
discussed their recommendations for each
member state for the next cycle
of the european semester at a joint
setting of parliament's economic and
employment committees
the commission has given member states
more time to tackle deficits
the commission
is
solidarity was a theme of martin
schultz's message as he attended the
gutenberg
conference the national school of
administration one of the biggest
civil service training academies french
presidents jacques cherek and francois
lund are just two of the famous names to
have attended the school please
please
european union
foreign